[Music]
despite huge differences in morphology
and biological structures all living
organisms do the same three basic things
they get food digested and excrete waste
materials living organisms require
energy to live some produce their own
food usually through photosynthesis we
call these autotrophs but many organisms
cannot make their own food we call these
heterotrophs and they eat among
heterotrophic single-celled eukaryotes
food is taken into the cell and various
methods but once it's there it's wrapped
by a membrane and forms something called
a food vacuole then the cell flushes
digestive enzymes inside the food
vacuole to start the digestion nutrients
are taken into the cytoplasm and the
waste material left in the vacuole then
basically fuses with the outer membrane
of the cell and what's left in the
vacuole is discharged into the
environment in some cases like inside
this beautiful single-celled nashua or
nada which feeds on filamentous
cyanobacteria content of the food
vacuole reacts with the digestive
enzymes and changes color but that
process takes time because each vacuole
formed at a different time they are in
different stages of digestion which
gives this cell its colorful polka-dots
but how do these heterotrophic organisms
get their food well in spite of a
remarkable amount of diversity a lot of
microorganisms use one of the same three
strategies forgetting their food some of
this will be familiar to the macro world
some of it
we'll not one of the less familiar is
filter-feeding which allows larger
organisms to consume suspended food
particles or much smaller organisms
there are filter feeders in the macro
world baleen whales come to mind but
while a whale must swim through giant
clouds of small organisms in the micro
cosmos your food can come to you some
filter feeders use hair like structures
called cilia to create a vortex that
brings other microorganisms or food
particles to the cell mouth these cilia
are specialized for this task and
they're beating creates a current that
expediently and beautifully directs
every nearby thing into the waiting
mouth of the microorganism the cilia are
often too small for us to see but you
can see their effects take a look at
these paramecia they're consuming tiny
tiny bacteria and you can see their
cilia causing small organisms to tumble
across them you can also see all of
their food vacuoles on the inside and if
you look very carefully you can see a
new food vacuole forming and getting
filled up with those tiny bacterial
cells
[Music]
some of the best and most obvious filter
feeders are rotifers micro animals that
use cilia to create swirling vortices
around their mouthparts you can see how
successful this feeding strategy is by
its belly full of algae cells every time
its mouth fills with more algae it
contracts to swallow the food now
observe these single-celled organisms
called stent errs they are much bigger
than most other micro organisms you can
actually see them with the naked eye and
they also use filter feeding to push all
of their algal food into their cell
mouths our second feeding mechanism may
be the most familiar and the most
exciting is called raptorial feeding
raptorial feeders selectively capture
prey and hunt other organisms in this
video you can see de Leptis hunting it
paralyzes one organism with a touch of
its drunk like proboscis and then it
pulls that organism into itself in a
process called phagocytosis many of
these micro organisms are armed with
something called toxic cysts these are
little harpoon-like structures filled
with toxins and they're located on a
particular part of the cell which the
micro organism uses for hunting these
tiny harpoons are then fired when they
come in contact with prey organisms
which then become immobilized
this is Bruce Aria it's a single-celled
organism with a huge mouth and things
have not gone well for the Paramecium
that is now inside it the Paramecium
dies immediately because of the toxicity
on the inside of the bursar eeeh so at
least it was quick now get ready for
some truly gorgeous footage of a micro
animals day going south first para de
Leptis immobilizes the rotifer or with
fired tox assists and the animal is
swallowed by the single-celled organism
as it swims away
[Music]
this is front onea which is a close
relative of paramecia but it lacks the
filter feeding habits of its relatives
and feeds pradesh ously on large diatoms
and filamentous cyanobacteria such as a
sila toria here though in this case it
turns out this front onea bit off a
little more than he could chew
another raptorial feeding style is
called histah fiji pista feigus
organisms such as these single-celled
collapse attack injured but live animals
or other single-celled organisms sucking
off hunks of tissue rather than
consuming whole organisms when they
attack an animal they enter wounds and
ingest tissue often attacking in groups
because their chemical sensing abilities
attract many of them from a distance
like microscopic vultures when a number
of them gather in one place it's hard to
avoid another macro world analog
piranhas devouring everything soft in no
time at all
there's a huge variety of raptorial
feeding this is just the beginning but
we wanted to show you one more before we
move on this is Vampirella an amoeba
with a suitable name it specializes in
feeding on filamentous algae first it
bores a hole through the algal cell wall
and then slurps out the gooey nutritious
cytoplasm our final feeding mechanism
for today at least is diffusion feeding
in which the predator just sits in the
same place relying on the prey to
accidentally make contact this is a
Helios OA it's a single celled amiibo
and because of its resemblance to the
Sun due to the rays coming out of its
cell it's sometimes called the Sun
animal fuel the Rays are called AXA
podía these are sometimes used in
locomotion and in this case for hunting
prey AXA podía are cytoplasmic
extensions meaning they're a part of the
cell membrane even though they look like
they're sticking out of it each one has
a central supporting rod of microtubules
that gives it this rigid structure the
AXA podía are coded in organelles that
discharge toxins when touched which
impair or even paralyze hylia zoa's prey
after the organism is captured those
microtubules are drawn back into the
cell thus retracting the AXA podía and
allowing the cell to swallow the unlucky
organism or prey is just engulfed by
extrusions from the cell called
pseudopodia
in this video a road of fur has been
captured by a Helia soul and is slowly
getting eaten by it now this is
something that happens fairly frequently
but we did capture something unusual
here while it was stuck to Gila
gazzola's Expo dia this rotifer actually
lays its egg
but neither egg or the rotifer is going
to escape this surprisingly
heartbreaking this is a subtour IAM it
cecilia just like Paramecium and Stentor
these organisms have hair like cilia
during the early stage of their life but
as adults they develop bundles of
tentacles just like in Helios OA these
tentacles are supported by an internal
cylinder of microtubules the tip of the
tentacles have extrusions these are
special structures that attach to and
immobilize any other ciliates that touch
them the tentacles eventually penetrate
the cell membrane of the prey and then
the contents of the prey is sucked out
through the tentacle in this clip a sec
Torian has caught four individual for de
cèlle
with its tentacles and is slowly sucking
their cytoplasm it looks a little like
the four de cèlle have the secretory and
surrounded but in fact they are
powerless to escape it it's a dangerous
world out there
the complex chemicals created by
organisms to sustain their life
necessarily are useful to other
organisms as building blocks and as fuel
and so predation evolved it's beautiful
it's constant and it's brutal thank you
for watching and for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us if you want to
see more from our master of microscopes
James check out jams germs on Instagram
and if you want to see more from us that
my friends is what the subscribe button
is for
[Music]